in the last video you learn about the
softmax there in the softmax activation
function in this video you deepen your
understanding of softmax classification
and also learn how to train a model that
uses a soft mask layer
recall our earlier example where the
open layer computes 0 as follows so
there are four classes sequels for then
zeros can be 4 by 1 dimensional vector
and we said we compute T which is this
temporary variable that performs element
wise exponentiation and then finally if
the activation function for your output
layer G of L is the softmax activation
function then the output will be this
basically taking the temporary variable
T and normalizing it to sum to 1 so this
then becomes a of L so you notice that
in the Z vector the biggest element was
5 and the biggest probability ends up
being dispersed probability the name
soft mass comes from contrasting it to
what's called a hard max which would
have taken the vector Z and mapped it to
this vector so hard max function will
look at the elements of Z and just put a
1 in the position of the biggest
elements of Z and then zeros everywhere
else and so there is a very hard max
where the bigger element gets a output
of 1 and everything else gives an output
of 0 whereas in contrast the soft max is
a more gentle mapping from Z to these
probabilities so I'm not sure if this is
a great name but that Lisa does the
intuition behind why we call it a soft
max always in contrast to the hard
max and one thing I did really show but
as alluded to is that softmax regression
or the softmax activation function
generalizes the logistics activation
function to see constants rather than
just two courses and it turns out that
if C is equal to 2 then soft max with C
equals to 2 essentially reduces to
logistic regression and I'm not
prove this in this video but the rough
outline for the prove is that is C
equals to two and if you apply softmax
then the output layer al well I'll put
two numbers the C equals two so maybe it
outputs 0.842 and 0.158 right these two
numbers always happens on to one and
because these two numbers always at the
center one they're actually redundant
and maybe don't need to bother to
compute two of them maybe we just need
to compute one of them and it turns out
that the way you end up computing that
number reduces to the way that logistic
regression is computing this single
whole point so that wasn't much of a
proof but the takeaway from this is that
top X regression is a generalization of
logistic regression to more than two
classes now let's look at how you would
actually train a neural network with a
soft max output layer so in particular
let's define the loss function you use
to Train in your network let's take an
example let's say you have an example in
your training sets where the output is
where the target output the grouchy
label is zero one zero zero so the
example from the previous video this
means that this is an image of a cat
because it falls into plus one and now
let's say that your new network is
currently outputting y hat equals so Y
hat will be a vector of probabilities
goes sum to one or point one zero point
four so you can check that sum to 1 and
this is going to be K L so the new net
was not doing very well in this example
because there's actually cat to miss and
only a 20% chance that this is a cat so
didn't do very well in this example so
what's the last function you want to use
to train this new network in softmax
qualification the last we typically use
is an extra sum of J equals 1 to 4 and
it's really sum from 1 for C in the
general case and I just use for here of
Y log or YJ log Y hat ok so let's look
at our single example above to better
understand what happens
notice that in this example y 1 equals y
3 equals y 4 equals 0 because those are
zeros and only y 2 is equal to 1 so if
you look at this summation all the terms
with 0 values of YJ u equal to 0 and the
only term you're left with is negative Y
2 log Y hat 2 because when you sum over
the indices of J all the terms will end
up 0 except when J is equal to 2 and
because y 2 is equal to 1 this is just
negative log Y hat - so what this means
is that if your learning algorithm is
trying to make this small because use
gradient descent to you know try to
reduce the loss on your training set
then the only way to make this small is
to make this small and the only way to
do that is to make Y hat to as big as
possible and these are probabilities so
it can never be bigger than 1 but this
kind of makes sense because if X for
this example is a picture of a cat then
you want to that output probability to
be as big as possible
so more generally what does loss
function does is it looks at whatever is
the ground truth class in your training
set and it tries to meet the
corresponding probability of that Clause
as high as possible if you're familiar
with maximum likelihood estimation
statistics this turns out to be a form
with maximum likely estimation but if
you don't know what that means don't
worry about it the intuition we just
talked about will suffice now this is
the loss on a single training example
how about the cost J on the entire
training set so the cost of the setting
the parameters you know and so on of all
the ways and biases you define that as
pretty much what you guess some will be
on Thai training set of the loss your
learning algorithms predictions summed
over your training examples and so what
you do is use gradient descent in order
to try to minimize this cost finally one
more implementational detail notice is
that would because sequel is equal to 4
y is a 4 by 1 vector and Y hat is also a
4 by 1
so if you are using a vectorized
implementation the matrix capital y is
going to be y 1 y 2 to y em stacked
horizontally and so for example if this
example up here is your first training
example then the first column of this
matrix Y will be 0 1 0 0 and then your
second example in the second example is
a dog who the third example is a none of
the above and so on and then this matrix
capital y will end up being a 4 by M
dimensional matrix and similarly Y hat
will be y hat one stack up horizontally
going through Y hat M so this is
actually why I had one or the output on
the first training example then so I had
to read this open 3 0.2 0.1 0.4 and so
on and why hide yourself will also be
for my M dimensional matrix finally
let's take a look at how you implement
gradient descent when you have a soft
max output layer so this output layer
will compute Z L which is C by 1 run our
example 4 by 1 and then you apply the
softmax activation function to get a L
or Y hat and then that in turn allows
you to compute the loss so we've talked
about how to implement the forward
propagation step of the neural network
to get these outputs and to compute that
loss how about the back propagation step
or gradient descent turns out that the
key step of the queue equation you need
to initialize back prop is this
expression that the derivative with
respect to Z at the last layer this
turns out you can compute this Y hat the
4 by 1 vector minus y the 4.1 Vestas you
notice that all of these are going to be
four by one vectors when you have four
classes and si by one in a more general
case and so this screen by our usual
definition of what is DZ this is the
partial derivative of the cost function
with respect to ZL if you're an expert
in calculus you can derive this yourself
or if you explain calculus you can try
to divide this yourself that using this
formula will also just work fine if you
ever need to enter in this from scratch
both this you can then compute D ZL and
then sort of start off the background
process to compute all the derivatives
you need throughout your neural network
but it turns out that in this week's
programming exercise we'll start to use
one of the deep learning programming
frameworks and for those foreign
frameworks usually it turns out you just
need to focus on getting the for profit
right and so long as you specify the
program where the four top parts the
pruning framework will figure out how to
do back prop or how to do the backward
pass for you so this expression is worth
keep in mind for if you ever need to
implement
softmax regression or soft by
classification from scratch although you
won't actually need this industries from
exercise because the programming
framework you use will take care of this
derivative computation for you so that's
it for soft max classification with it
you can now implement learning
algorithms to catalyze the inference
into not just one of two classes but one
of the different classes next I want to
show you some of the deep learning
programming frameworks which can meet
you much more efficient in terms of
implementing deep learning algorithms
let's go onto the next video to discuss
that